This is how Easter eggs are made.
And don't walk. Or bike.
It's episode 32 of IMG!
Best haircut... ever.
And creepy t-shirt Abraham Lincoln.
But hunting is awesome.
Oh.
Lishoffs rules. He made the Simpson's alphabet,
a superhero alphabet and curser bullies.
An equally rare talent is found in Jeff Blazer.
He's the guy who photoshopped the famous
Orange Frog. He also made a geographical Pac-Man
and proved that Jim Henson was the puppet.
Europe is naughty. And here's yet another false
motion illusion. Your brain can't figure it
out, so as you look around it warps and stretches.
I suggest going fullscreen.
Chicks love cats. Chicks love cats. Cats
love dogs. Dogs love everything. And cats
love butt gymnastics. You know, like the balance
beam. Balance beer.
This isn't a joke. This is the last thing
you will see before you die. Can you find
the cat?
But we should move on to girls in costume,
tied up. Can you save them?
Reddit had fun last week with police from
awesome cities like the Flippin police, the
Climax police, and the infamous Sandwich police.
Princess Peach. Grrrrrocery shop yellow, green,
black, red.
Deviant artist Meirou created real-life Disney
princessess. Here's Ariel and Flounder.
Don't look, hey, wait a second.
Let me just turn on the light... line.
But I prefer my lamps soft and gooey and
flowey. And my common objects huge. You might
need gloves this big to touch whatever these
kids are looking at.
Maybe they're watching Facebook.com/Vsaucegaming,
where you guys have submitted 5,428 images
as of the very moment I'm saying this.
Casey showed us extreme kissing, dance mode,
and Marshall dyed an egg in honor of Vsauce.
Trude matured things up with this actual last
name and Carl asked us to cover up the top
half of this equation.
And now it's time to watch LÜT on our other
channel, Vsauce2. It's a different channel
with different types of stuff, so be sure
you're subscribed, click right here to watch LÜT.
And as always,
thanks for watching.